on house bill 417
and i was informed senator gaiden that
you have
a re-written bill that you wish to share
with us
do that sure thank you
okay just hold the press
so
i consider this arguably one of the most
important
films this session because you're
dealing with the checks and balances
over
this is a bill that was drafted over the
weekend the amendment that was drafted
represents uh the work
of the senate
consonants with the governor's office
it is similar in some respects and not
similar in others
that's the reason here is i think it's
imperative that we arrive at some
agreement we cannot continue to operate
in those churches whatsoever
or you can read it yourself whichever is
your preference
the soul has totally rewritten the bill
correct yes you should hit the hot
center gotta get the high points sure
all right
all right so the governor has the power
to declare the state of emergency
okay it lasts for 30 days as soon as
practicable
the governor has to notify speaker and
the senate president for the impending
issuance
whether he knows he's going to do it
he's got to let him know
and he has to provide the description of
the works orders okay
we also can declare state of emergency
current resolution of the house and
senate
has to specify nature with the emergency
political subdivisions
very subject to it conditions that
brought it about the duration of the
emergency if it's less than 30 days
this will terminate automatically 30
days unless it's renewed from the
same procedure set forth above so the
governor would notify the house and
senate
leadership and then it says
i can continue to renew it as many times
as necessary to protect the safety
involved during the academics
um if he finds that it's no longer
justified the governor issues an
executive order terminating
it legislation terminated or any
emergency order issued there
by the current resolution adopted by a
majority vote in the east chamber
power to review the state of emergency
to renew a declaration shall terminate
once such a resolution is adopted
doesn't conclude him from declaring a
new state of reverse for a different
problem
remember the house or the senate
or legislative officers or staff can be
essentially prevented from coming to
conflict
to do business uh considering whether or
not to terminate an emergency order
some reason that people can't travel
we're exempt from that to come down to
discuss the emergency orders
it says no federal state uh i'm sure no
federal private or other non-state
is grant for funds essentially over a
hundred thousand dollars should be
accepted until it's approved by the
fiscal committee
governor chelsea admitted to the
chairperson and the
report that the fiscal committee does
not approve within five days
by business days the governor may accept
and expend the funds without further
action
by the fiscal committee okay so that
says the fiscal committee
has been notified and doesn't care to
act on it
the governor can do it to us
that would be my understanding of this
yes
it doesn't accept or reject it
essentially since it wasn't active
circumstances requiring expedited action
for the immediate health safety and
welfare of the citizens of new hampshire
the government has so authority to
accept and extend funds to iran
and it says as well the governor has a
duty to provide a list of all
expenditures pursuant to the supervision
of your state diversity to the executive
council for informational purposes
for purposes of transparency that's the
best basic build we're starting from
necessarily well
it represents right in my mind it
doesn't doesn't
really change what we already have
the clever gives them seven more days
it doesn't uh it's taking away any check
that
the legislator legislature has on on
executive orders on renewals
it's basically what he can do right now
how is this different than what you can
do right now
the trunk cases will do so much that's
the only thing
it also gives us specific authority to
invalidate an executive order without
pending the state
which is something that we were very
concerned with last year
my biggest issue difference between
if the legislature could was possible
for them to meet it required an
affirmative vote to extend the state of
emergency
there wasn't provision if it could be
not having that in there i'm
very concerned about it because there's
a difference between
us having to take some action to
extend the state of emergency or to go
along with it rather than having to take
the legislature has
the ability to stop it but is it too
constitutional for the legislature to
have the ability to give permission for
it
i mean that's a discussion i understand
my understanding is that the
state of emergency the governor has the
power to grant
statute so i don't see the constitution
yes thank you oh i was
wondering if i could ask about
section five um bringing legislators
into
into concord uh you know for the
purposes of
you know the conversation voting
whatever it might be around the state of
emergency
do we want to build into there the
possibility
that we might need to do this remotely
should we not be able to get here
no that's uh that's section four
section four sorry number five quick
page two question
i was on the right page and looking at
it but do you want to
consider that there for the safety of
all involvement there may be a time
where
we cannot physically get in and i don't
think we should put
people at risk on the road including
highway workers
other public safety workers well we
could do this remotely is there
a reason that we don't want to do that
do we have to be physically present so
um well starting with that section in
general
the intent of the section was not i mean
because this is already in the
constitution
that we can't be arrested we have to
bail on our way to congress this already
exists so this just causes what's in the
constitution
the intent of this was so that
representatives and senators
could go out and see what's going on in
their communities
um if there's a restriction you can't
travel you know
everyone has to stay home how can we
represent people we can't even go out
and visit and see what's going on if
there's an issue that was the intent to
put this in there
so if everyone's locked into the home
including the people's representatives
how can we how can we so so this section
was put in there with the specific
intent that we would be exempt
for the purposes of being able to go out
and meet with and see what's going on
with our constituents
what this does is just copy what's
already in the constitution that says we
can't be arrested
we held available on our way on our way
to recession
i'm not sure that that would cover going
open to
the community or whatever because
said that we
is
well if you want to see what was in the
house version
the handiest way to do so and it says
on page four members of the legislature
shall be
exempt from any emergency orders that
would infringe upon their ability to
travel
or otherwise conduct their business
representatives
which is significantly different than
the language
i think that
just is a question here and it deals
with conduct their business
as representatives of the people would
that include
coming to concord does that going to not
allow the governor to
close the state house and the
legislative office building
so i'll say so yes
okay at least at least
to close it to the legislature it's
possible you could say members of the
public
and not the legislatures but if if
the purpose of this section is for
members of the legislature to uh
conduct their business as
representatives of the people shouldn't
the people have the right
to see what they're doing
so it would negate any order that the
governor
would give for closing the state house
or the legislative office building that
you could close down every single thing
in this state but the one thing that
would stay open would be the legislature
[Music]
and we would continue to do whatever
business that we needed to do while we
were here
thank you very much just a quick
question as to whether
the governor can stop the legislature
from meeting or is it the legislature
itself that
stops itself from
i believe the legislature has to stop
itself right so
i don't think any governor's order could
affect the legislature to separate
branch
i don't think anything in the language
um
that the legislature should be somewhere
over the state house if they wanted to
originally
yes
i think that this this provision like
it's i think really needs
to be flushed out more
yes look let's
let's see if we can flesh it out a
little bit what are the issues that
anyone sees
with exempting legislators incentives
from being
able to conduct business in their
communities
what you have is a two-tiered system you
will have
members of the public say like what we
went through last year
or the governor said look we want you to
stay at home
but we're exempting those legislators
they can go out and do whatever they
want to do
i think that that would cause an issue
with with the people
um you say going out and conducting
business well
what are you talking about when you're
talking about conducting business
are you talking about um meeting your
constituents how are you going to meet
your constituents if you're in lockdown
what are you what are you looking for
that's what i'm i'm trying to figure out
what are you trying to get to what
specifically
are you looking at that you feel that
because
we were in a lockdown you could not
conduct your business or do anything
else as a representative because i would
argue with you there
that i was very very busy people were
calling me um we were skyping face
timing
i mean we use technology to stay in
contact with our constituents um
so i don't see why we even need this
well a couple of things um first of all
don't focus on copic 19 because this is
prospective this is um contemplating
future emergencies so
what i envisioned and i work with the
rest of
the folks in the community as well is if
there's a
walk down all right you have to stay in
stock for whatever reason
if people don't have technology can't
reach you the phones are down
there's an issue in town and that they
need you to come see
so you can relate to the rest of the
legislature the store or the business
at the local government if the
legislature
and the representatives of the people
can't go out and see what's going on
which is our job it's not a two-tiered
system they elected us to represent them
to see these things it's not like we're
saying legislators can go to mcdonald's
but you can't
we're out there to be able to report
back to the president legislature
and the governor what we're seeing and
represent them
i see a huge difference between them
i can i can understand where he's coming
from having gone down to mississippi for
hurricane katrina when there's
no form of communication cell phone
otherwise um
that the only way being with fema get
out
and interacting with people because
there was no way to be okay
um it was impossible so i see kind of
where he's coming from on that
that in the spectrum every bit we have a
another blockbuster storm of some sort
that knocks out everything
um we all know that once the power goes
out uh cell phones go
down computers go down um we can be
without them for quite some time
so i can kind of see where he's coming
from on that
in his first communications uh a few
years ago we had that huge ice storm
people came to my house if people wanted
to
talk to me about something they came to
my house we had no
telephone no internet we were out for
almost three weeks
so that was one way and um
they would come to my house and say can
you come to my house i want to show you
something
and i would do that so i i do think that
people can be very creative when it
comes to
staying in contact with your
constituents the thing that i one of the
things that i'm concerned about
is is this going to be a problem
for our first responders because
they're going to they're out i mean if
it's an ice storm if it's a snowstorm or
a hurricane
tornado or whatever they're out there
trying to help people
and all of a sudden now you see all
these other people coming out
what's going on what's what's happening
what are we what do we need to do
are we going to make their jobs harder
by going you know by traveling and
conducting
whatever business you feel is
appropriate during this time
are we going to make it difficult for
them final technical point
that section was unchanged in both the
house and the senate versions
so i would be very hesitant to yank it
out
so apparently we think that it's
there are times when it's necessary
right
so it's just that we're working off of
this amendment and it's not in this
amount
so i'm inclined to support it on that
ground alone unless there's a
particularly good reason okay it was my
understanding this replaced
everything so it's mine as well but we
still have to agree on that yes sir
so two things one i
i was my understanding this was a
replacement as well so as we're moving
through this i
was working off of that assumption you
know if i may number
two i think that that senator
carson is correct that we don't
we have to be careful about if as
representatives of the government if we
are making ourselves
present on disaster scenes um it
should be in coordination with local
emergency management or homeland
security
not as i just i'm going to show up
for an example when i was the mayor well
but because it
creates more first it creates more of a
presence of the public
and sometimes you have to manage their
safety as well as manage the safe give
the situation
so i think that that should be
considered when i was the mayor of
lebanon we had a
we had a number of problems with
microbursts and rain and i remember i
called
the fire chief and said if you'd like um
i i would like to come down and see
what's going on
on behalf of the city but i'm not going
to come until you think it's safe enough
for me to go and i coordinated with him
as a local emergency manager so for the
safety of all
if we want to have that available
there just should be you shouldn't just
be able to show up you need to according
to somebody i think
that's like i understand and i agree
with you completely but i don't think we
should put in statute that we don't
trust the intelligence
of the legislators to you know
accessibly an emergency
which is what that sort of thing would
be
i mean um
as was mentioned if the telecoms are
down you know
but even without that uh you might be
better off with
uh you know a large but limited number
of legislators
going out to see people or see what's
going on rather than having
a potentially larger number of people
trying to get the legislators home
in that situation
child guns are down having to cover your
house like
possible in some circumstances but not
in others
or at least a good idea
representative mcguire with all due
respect i'm not saying that people don't
know how to act sensibly including
members of the legislature
but as a as a first responder i've been
trained
in terms of like what the you know the
first thing they teach you is
safety of the scene and i also
understand what it's like to be managing
crowd control
you know and trying to take care of
a situation let's take care of everyone
else so i'm not looking to
prohibit that as much as have a way so
that
you know the legislator wants to be
there or is going to come but there's
some connection
so i'm not saying they don't know how to
act sensitively those respectfully those
are your words i'm just
trying to take it from my point of
training that i want that to be given
consideration of these conversations
i'm just inclined to put that much level
of detail
into the status it gives me addresses to
emergencies
that you don't know what kind of an
emergency it is
i mean if it's an ice storm you better
want people to be very careful about
traveling because it's dangerous yeah
if it's something like oh that's not
necessary you just want to control it
together and then coming to your house
depends on where your house is
thank you i don't think because i also
first responded training and i agree
with you you don't want chaos
having said that i don't think this
exempts um legislators from having to
obey
offloaders of people who are in charge
of the scene this just says that
an emergency order that locks down
doesn't lock down the legislature
so if eyes the legislators show up at a
fire and the fire exchange says hey
you're in the way you need to go and i
state legislature i can stay
i can be arrested this just says that
i'm not locked
in by the governor's emergency order
this doesn't say i'm exempted
from all the rest of the rules that
apply in laws
that at the scene a fire chief or a
police chief did you laugh in the water
you disobey it yourself progresses like
any other citizen
all i'm trying to do with this piece is
to say i don't have to stay in my house
i can go up and see what's going on to
help my constituents
so i can report back to the house so i
don't think this
creates quite the this because i
understand what you're you're saying
it's 30 40 let's let it show up you know
it's i mean it's a little about the
press there and everything
but i think that i don't think that this
does i think it just
lets you out of your house it doesn't
extend you from the rest of the walls
okay thank you does that make sense yeah
so if i'm the manager you are
you are proposing that we include that
language
that was um it was
that is different in this amendment but
was included in both members of the
house
and i think that since the arrested or
held to bail
part is in the constitution we don't
need to repeat it
and share that question
just for my identification
why are we automatically assuming that
we're now operating from this amendment
we haven't adopted this and we still
yes the reason we're doing this
amendment is that various members of the
house who are concerned about this issue
have been worked in the senate
and they've talked to me and that's why
we have this which is intent
because the house and the senate
versions have
much the same intent but there's
language differences
so this is an attempted compromise and
so
i think i thought it would be easier if
report from this
but on the other hand we can use
like in this case i think both the house
and the senate version have better
language
on this particular paragraph
i agree
do you agree we should give up on the uh
the governor will assist the members of
the house
and senate to get the uh they see the
fake government
so the uh
so is since we're on the h2
anyone have issues with the
proportions i like the um
list of expenditures
so this is
i think that's good yeah and everything
under this just to make sure claire is
when he's
handsy this list of expenditures over to
the governor to the council
that that's 91a and that's available for
the public
yes absolutely um
[Music]
fiscal being smaller you know meeting
remote might be practical
we have to concede to actually prevent
that to happen
the governor could do an emergency order
i suppose allowing it
but uh if not good thing you remotely
without
is that is that something that could be
covered under house rules though
well isn't fiscal is that a point
okay that's right the other thing is
that
fiscal meets year round so
and the government couldn't authorize
because it's a separate branch so we'd
have to put it in here
i think
senate forces two people i suppose you
can work on that the house
i don't see enough i don't think you
have a bandwidth
it's just trying to organize the
procedures i don't
think it would work well i've had
smaller meetings you've spent all your
time saying oh where's the new
with somebody themselves yeah
okay you wouldn't get i don't think
that's well especially you'd have to
allow the public well that's possible
and that we'll know but it adds more
people
in a raised hands and asking questions
well if you like the column
that heats bandwidth well yeah i've seen
i've seen things that were
the numbers go pretty quickly because
because one thing is people people can't
if there's other people talking
somebody speaking to say something get
recognized
it doesn't work but i have
it's a very very broad
i was noticing it it also appears to be
in the conflict of number five
i've seen my numbers that are around
six that are in the 50s
your job may not have started yeah it
appears to nullify five
yeah this is
this is
extradited action because to me not
necessarily carry the same
sense as emergency
immediate health safety and welfare
let's
define the immediate lawyer yes oh i was
actually centered continue because i
think we're on the same ladder
[Music]
language
defining emergency action
that i think that piece needs work
i agree because i think it makes uh
part five moment five basically
although i i can see the necessity
for some form of it right but um
something comes up
in this you know 24 hours
let's just close five days right we need
to we need to massage that i
well i think one thing is that the
um
there's got to be notification right
there that
fiscal and the executive council
notified within
24 hours and
they could decide to do something
remote physically
we're stuck
we need a definition
i think that simply a notification
within 24 hours should
allow either book to
24 hours so
if it's something that requires
expedited action from immediate health
and safety
right that sounds to me like something
that needs to be
no happening right now i mean i think
when
uh
in canada said you know my my my plane's
leaving
um leaving china do you want me to
can you buy some more ppe to fill it up
okay that would that would be short
numbers
but that's the sort of thing that that i
think that should be notified
after the agreement you know at least
notify everybody
would we want to manage
[Music]
but i think just some sort of
notification
within a reasonable amount of time to um
to the senate president the speaker of
the house
and and the chair of the fiscal
committee so they at least know what's
going on
and i think that's that's reasonable
because you don't
you don't want to try you don't want
yeah you don't want to micromanage the
situation because there could be a
thousand and one different situations
[Music]
i i agree with what you just said my
only concern is notification is great
but
what is it how is it a chat
okay i deemed this to be an emergency
this could be a health issue this
notification notification notification
that's not a check
how so how would we turn it into please
you're letting the legislative body know
what the governor whoever the governor
is
is doing that is the check and then
once the senate president the speaker of
the house
they know what's going on if they choose
an alternative action they have the
ability to do that
right now they don't have the ability to
do that they would find out
pretty much what everybody else would
find out here
if you would say within 24 hours you've
got to
notify the senate president the speaker
of the house the chair of the fiscal
committee
what you're doing that's the check
because then it becomes
more transparent right now there really
isn't a lot of transparency and
they and they can in fact
call a session cancel if next
okay that's so that that's not right i
think that's the truth
i guess my question goes to
under this provision the governor spends
the money
say it was on a saturday or sunday for
playing over
bringing ppe back for that purpose
how does the house and the senate
rescind
that appropriation because that's when
they're allowing us to do that
i think what we really want is what we
have is the transparency on how the
appropriations are
and i don't think the 24-hour notice is
necessary because right below we
say within 30 days all expenditures have
to be reported to the council
so i don't know why notifying the senate
president
the speaker of the house within 24 hours
when i don't think they could stop that
from happening
um would be any different than what we
can do
with 38 notifications so i think we're
checking the check
right below a couple thoughts on that
one is
know if if fiscal or whatever else
really disapproved of what was going on
at least they have earlier notification
and could take action to prevent any
further similar expenditures it's not
perfect but there is a problem that you
could have legitimate issues with
something needs to be done right now
but if they've got notification 24 hours
you know they could say well we're going
to get together you know
avoid that emergency order that you did
or something else and there'd be some
discussion going on
so if you had somebody that the
legislature would help you is going a
little rogue
they put interviewing earlier so i think
that's the other question on the
notification should the executive
council be happy with us
i originally thought they should be
emergency
there are so many scenarios where you
could have to expend funds
of rich collapse
state under a circumstance
so it's too separate
you could you could scratch the other
circumstances
where the third
or spend a lot of money
i just remember years ago when um
governor lynch was governor and i think
bob you were in the house as well
um with the fall with the floods in
austin
and um the governor had declared a state
of emergency but
we had a special session if you remember
he brought the legislature in to expend
money
to uh to provide relief so
it does happen i mean there is a
procedure i just
i'm just really concerned about
micromanaging this process
that you know why we think we're trying
to create a balance we're really not
and we're tying the hand of the governor
whoever the governor
will be to act accordingly
in a time of a state of emergency
and i think the governor needs to have
some
flexibility in order to deal with the
different types
of problems that we could
face and i just think we just need to be
really careful about tying the hands
chris
we're just limiting to a declared state
of emergency
okay because he's got to notify ahead of
time because we as fiscal have five days
to get back
otherwise he's definitely thought
this is a pretty good adult suspension
to hand it off i was just going to say i
don't think we need to
add in the language regarding a state of
emergency
into that paragraph because it's already
under the powers emergency powers of the
state of emergency
okay i think you're being redundant if
you put state of emergency back in there
because
you're right 445 is all about
[Music]
emergencies
we'll just start with other
circumstances
thank you
[Music]
the qualification of the president's
speaker
chair of fiscal and executive committee
within 24 hours
so that they can take any action if it's
necessary otherwise they're just
better is it possible under what any way
it's currently to me
without unless the government doesn't
first
at least some of the times
[Music]
you'll have to have legislation in order
to do that
from the notifications so
no for the remote here
so that i'll won't get spelled out in a
piece of legislation
um
and that's the problem you need the
language first
and then you can you can add this as a
separate section to that
bill but if you put it in here and if
something happens to the legislation all
of a sudden you've got this and what do
you do with it
um
can we just say if appropriate
physical company may be remotely
periodic
i don't know we haven't
[Music]
all requirements for 911
and
well it's your decision um just how fast
what the need to be able to happen
the provision the right to know uh you
could write it there's
something that says the provision of the
right to know while it requires a forum
to be present
in a place does not apply to any
specific means of this
so that would be simply accepting the
requirement that they need
i less need the notification section
more right
that's interesting
that's why
you want to bring in
is is there a way i mean i keep going
back to this
um on page four this
members of the legislature shall be
exempt from emergency orders
that would infringe upon their ability
to travel and conduct their business as
representatives of the people
um because i
want to make sure that it's very clear
that it's
you know they could own a business i'm
just going to use the word a bar
and that's how they meet constituents by
opening their business and people come
to the bar and they get to talk to them
that's counter to what what
what you really want to do is there a
way that we could strengthen that and do
we need to
have to travel can it just be
would infringe upon their ability to
conduct their business as
representatives of the people
um because if that's what you're getting
at um
[Music]
i i just i know that we had agreed to
that
i just
it's i understand that you want to stay
in contact with your constituents i
think that that's important
um but i don't want to set us above
an emergency order an emergency
order is for everyone and it's for
everyone's health safety and welfare and
i would submit sharon
that i have many constituents that would
expect me
to visit to visit their homework
to the situation where just collapsed
not in any way to interfere with
certain subject to right fire chief
ambulance whatever the case may be
[Music]
and so my perspective is that's almost
an expectation
they like to seek me out helping
engage myself in the process of solving
the problem
the legislative perspective not from
operation
and if i may to your powerpoint it
doesn't exempt
anyone but the legislators so people
can't come to your borrower to meet you
because they'd be violating the
trafficker
to go see whoever needs to be seen
doesn't exempt anyone else
i want to make sure the other thing is
that this past year we had the americans
that said every once they don't accept
essential workers
i mean we couldn't just declare
legislators essential workers
well why don't we do that because who
knows what the
language of the next emergency order
would be but
in this case there was we had a two-tier
system
you know potential workers and everybody
else right so
this would simply say that legislators
are by definition essential workers
if a future governor chooses to oppose a
somewhat executive
you know that would infringe on their
ability to conduct their business as
representatives for people
sound strong enough to meet but i'm not
sure what was in the board
well if we take the travel out then and
the telephone systems are down
[Music]
those three words
even the ability to promote
would it be appropriate to put
something into that section that
um there are penalties if someone
should violate that section
i think that doesn't doesn't
seem to fit the rest of this okay
okay they could be subject to um
[Music]
i don't know go to the complaints can be
made to the legislative
ethics committee or they could be
subject to censure
okay i don't know if that needed to be
spelled out i'm just really concerned
about
people taking in legislative state
abusing this
um i'm using this statue
so the other deterrent is
if something lipstick does it
that it can be made publicly
really you know the ends and
limits that disciplines legislators
voters yeah can we say that
why is
does not include the ability to conduct
business
as a legislator that was your personal
just to make it a little clearer
well i think it's pretty clear conduct
their business as representatives of the
people
okay that's i think that's pretty clear
very quickly i try not to get frustrated
but the point of this
legislation in this very meeting is to
discuss
and bring in a future governor's
ability to do things without checking
with the legislature and now we're
talking about
criminal penalties for legislators i
think
is trying to define the languages
when i met the governor last week he was
concerned
that the language of
one version i'm not sure which foreign
legislature
met and did not take up
a state of emergency that it would be
cancelled
by inaction i don't i don't think that's
the case
either okay
okay
um but allowing the state of emergency
will be extended
without the affirmative approval of the
legislature i
i think that's the whole foundation the
whole thing yeah
and that's less of a time critical thing
because
you know we know when it's going to
expire we know whenever
the personal house version there was a
provision if the house truly could not
be that the government
even this past year if
i think that that after the first
renewal we should be improving your
goals
and even this past year we could have
met
it's about 45 or 50 days after the
initial declaration
and we did in fact and we did in fact
take up the
end of the emergency but failed so i
think that
the question is
the concern is that the reason
legislature has
the ability to limit the executive
authority of government i think the
answer is yes
in an emergency right so let's define
the period of time
that's important part of the argument
for changing the 21 and 30 days of the
house
was it was tied to that requirement that
we had with
extended and we wanted to provide a long
enough period that it covered
you know all the normal emergencies
which are mainly weather related
so we didn't want a situation where you
know there's some weather like you know
it can dry storm that
lasted longer than a few weeks 22 days
right right that you know there wouldn't
be a situation where the tail ended up
extended emergencies
that's pretty much all the state of
emergencies other than you know code
we're trying to think of other things
that could be a longer state of
emergency
you know they've seen more of a lot of
something but
short of that um this wouldn't go into
effect but the concern is if you have a
government that
right here wrongly decides to have a
really long-term state of
emergency this guy the legislature's got
to be a check and it's very different
having a requirement that we have to
vote to approve an extension that is
stopping
right and one's much more powerful
so what negative 60 days
the process of getting things going with
emergency
federal relations
well yeah i mean i would be willing to
extend it to 60 days
if the legislature had to
[Music]
it's wisely so it would have caused beth
if we just said okay we end the
statement because
he was to use a phrase it's too big and
fair
it's tied into everything it's going to
finance this time the business is
turning into public safety
so the longer you let it go on let's
check the more difficult
it will be to stop it
so it's 60 days too much or is it just
right
open i'm just trying to yeah flesh it
out so
i just i'm gonna dial back to very
basic questions why do we want
to why do we want to stop it why do we
want someone we want to say
this what is the legislature want to
manage a state of emergency at a level
where they're saying
we're going to stop this or we're going
to continue this
you know if we have checks and balances
in places it has to do with money and we
trust
our chief executive that's i've always
struggled with this i'm not
being difficult or obstructionary but
i'm just trying to understand
why we're saying we have to get in on
that granular level and say no
i i do think that this is i think the
compromise that the senate came up with
because
i can remember talking about this during
our first
beating on it and i i pushed back in the
same vein so i'm just going to
push back then i think we've come really
far i appreciate the work that senator
veda
and folks have done but why are we
getting like i think we've put some good
guard bureaus in place
what are we going to do and why when why
do we
this is just i'm just asking and i'm not
being difficult
um i don't like to look at it as
we the legislature saying we don't
trust the executive or we need to get
into the business
executive but after a certain period of
time
it's not us it's the citizen i trust the
citizens of an answer more than my
choice to go
if they decide in whole through their
representatives and senate house
we've had enough of this that's how
democracy works
that they don't but when you leave it up
to one person to say we're going to do
this at
infinity and you guys just sit there and
be quiet that's where all this
frustration came from
they had no voice right i think
i think the voice is there looking at
this because you can with the
resolution you can end it so it still is
there if
the people choose but it's like
flipping the coin 50 one way 50 to the
other see the legislature ends it more
but the 20 is going to be much more
difficult
once it's already placed and it becomes
you know such a huge entity that you end
the event with people because
systems have been put in place you just
pull that rug up underneath them
for example having ended it you'd have
lost all this business ppe money all
this stuff that already been put in
place
versus had we approved it in the first
place i think there's a difference
between
ending and approving to go forward
another point is that
the supporters
after the first couple started
delving into policy issues and that's
something that the legislature hasn't
has a responsibility for us
what's an essential business but you
know this
the lesson the license and things you
know we
when we reviewed the executive orders we
decided to incorporate some of them into
statute
we've approved them there were others
that we said well
we don't really think this was that good
an idea but then
we won't let it happen again so if we
had been able to review some of the
policy choices
the decision to shut down non-essential
businesses by
listing them was something that was a
major policy choice that a lot of people
disagreed with
and i will say that's probably one of
the main reasons why i
agreed with your version at the
legislation needs to be because of
if we're going to come in to okay the
emergency orders which i think we
should have a saying when it deals with
policy then we can at the same time deal
with
the extension of the state of emergency
and that was
one of the reasons why that his
position versus the other because of the
emergency laws and
being put on policy which is
this body's job policy issues
um so a couple
things one is i felt that uh because we
didn't
we're in a position to approve the
extension that
the legislature was advocating it's it's
responsible for the people and i got
that
i was contacted by a number of
constituents and other people
that weren't happy with what's going on
and i think some of them would have been
happy if at least the legislature got
together and said yes we need to
continue this
so i see value in that and the other
thing is i'm willing to go along with
removing the language that's what we can
to approve
individual executive orders just like
the language in there
that we can get rid of them
if if we have to get together at least
approve
extension um because it's
it's easy i think to
for the legislature to stand back and
just not get involved and i think that's
what happened here
i think forcing the election we're gonna
i mean we may mostly agree
that the emergency work the emergency
emergency has to continue
but you know forcing the legislature to
have to
get together and improve it i think is
very important
you know if nothing else we're putting
our stamp of approval on it supporting
the governor
you know if we think that's the right
thing to do and also that would force us
to get together
and it would be the opportunity that
least kind of set up an opportunity to
review individuals that have most
orders which some may not differ
so i think having us having to act to
extend it is
it's very yeah if it's 45 days
so
[Music]
30. and
on line 19 where it says unless it is
reused by
the same procedures
particularly the rest of that group
that one
45 data efforts declaration unless it is
reviewed
by a majority vote of each chamber of
the legislature prior to termination
in the event the legislature is unable
to convene
the state of emergency shall and
emergency orders shall
automatically extend in 14-day
increments or until the legislature can
convene to vote on the renewal whichever
comes first
and the governor has the power to have
time to end it
[Music]
i don't see a legislature being
frivolous
or political if you're in a state of
emergency that's some serious business
i'm not naive enough to think that there
won't be politics played
but i would have to hope that a majority
of your citizens would say you know what
we support this and help you also help
us get out there now
there may be circumstances that citizens
are not aware of
the things that they're not aware of
that the government is
also and so in that sense we can
hopefully
share them
and that was really one of my points in
drafting this was that
the governor's made a lot of decisions
and and
i i don't want to criticize him because
i don't know what he knows i mean he had
some real experts testified to him
that said you know what this decision
that's the right decision
we didn't so all we knew was that order
happened our constituents say hey why
did you do that
i don't know so but it's the same
presentation has to be made to the house
to extend the order
and now we all know we can all tell our
constituents this is a good order
we have done this last year we did meet
probably
45 or
so let's take this to an extreme let's
take a situation with the governor
and we cannot disclose to our people
no but i think the federal authorities
would take precedent they would take
over
information if you're talking about a
nuclear biological weapon you're going
to tell them security is going to be in
it's
going to be out of our hands
well no because this is a national
threat
code was not international
so we're going to start limiting it
and say we have to improve and we're
going to have to foreclose
the legislature's meetings been opened
it's a threat to the state i think that
was recently
discussing the strategy of being
involved in war states in the world war
but i think we're applying terrorism
yeah so there's an exception
in the constitution on public access
no i'm not the state there's an
exemption in 91a for
emergency response
mr um
i think we've sort of agreed on the
intent
and where would we work it so we working
from this
draft draft amendment
we created the first paragraph
on line 17 we would extend the statement
to 45 days to
simplify things yeah on the next part a
we would make it for 45 days under the
house version
which requires that the
legislature to approve a renewal beyond
45 days
but if we can't make them
14 weeks extensions as necessary and
as far as the emergency orders go we
agree that we
can terminate them individually oh yes
but we do not get involved in that
that's
[Music]
we would change that we don't terminate
a state from moving
we may terminate any emergency order
like current resolution
and um
well it's still a state of emergency
though right yeah what we just
we just turn it into words right we
approve the state of the number
they continue to state an emergency and
we
may terminate the
but we can't terminate the state
emergency itself except for by not
voting to extend no no
no not true okay yeah you're right we
should be able to do it
yeah okay um i think we need to make it
very clear that
it should be an up or down motion that
we shouldn't be able to table these
things
if i mean if this is about
if i'm like we need to make sure
that there is a a majority vote and it's
not the table
agreed about the tables
but i could define the required
well no but does the senator mean
present in voting
versus in other words if so many people
don't show up
should it be just a majority of the
members president voted yes
for those of you that haven't met my
name is james kelly i'm the governor's
legal counsel and the naval academy
graduates
i think one of the concerns with the
language as presented is it
allows one chamber to tell the state of
emergency
um if one chamber were to table
it in other words to terminate that
folks state emergency would that field
and so that runs up two charges
you can't guarantee that both chambers
will agree what happens if one chamber
votes to continue and one of us
determines
to continue the motion has to be
determined
yeah we can
um
letting the governor create a state of
emergency remain in a state of emergency
is an extraordinary situation grants
extraordinary powers the legislature is
to some extent stepping aside
i might keep letting him run things
which in any real emergency might be
necessary
but the question is if we have a
reasonable if we have a real emergency
[Music]
right there's a lot of dynamics that the
legislature have
to prove and one is as has been
mentioned the governor is going to
you know probably need to provide the
legislative
information
and there might also be you know some
amount of negotiating
about what happens in controversial
disorders and other things which i think
is a
admissible interaction and we're talking
about
giving them basically a free range of 45
days
thank you representative mcguire so just
for clarification
um representative leakes largest
blackouts
roy and lovely is easy but i know it's a
problem that's all right i'll get there
so what you correct me if i'm wrong what
you're saying is
that if we if we or you don't think it's
an emergency
then we could say no we don't think it's
an emergency and tell the governor
like we don't think this is any work to
see our judgment is
it isn't so we're going to stop this
right
okay what again why why would
we where
what do you have any examples if we're
like how would you determine
or how would we determine what's an
emergency or not what puts us in that
position
that's that's our jobs make decisions
the governor if if there's any concern
about it being a real emergency
i would expect the governor to be out
there telling us why it's a real
emergency
because i mean this one like i said if
we
voted in in april for may we would have
said yes it's an emergency we
will continue we'll be authorized but by
august
there were a lot of people saying it's
not an emergency anymore it's a
public health issue that we need to deal
with but it's not an
emergency and so at that point you've
got
a difference of opinion on
whether it should be continued but it
wasn't at the beginning because
the general senator raises another
concern
if there's a federal requirement for it
to be a declared state of emergency do
we
have a different or separate type of
statement
you know i understand why we want to do
this but i mean
i it's a delicate balance here um
and you know i i
i see where there's some micromanaging
that
maybe we shouldn't be doing um
we've got to trust whoever the governor
is that they're doing the right thing
and granted there should be some things
that we can do on the other side
but we shouldn't be tying the hands of
the governor
there he's going to get information much
faster than
the legislature is going to get and if
he has to declare
a state of emergency or start issuing
emergency
orders the governor whoever he or she
is going to be should be able to do that
we should be able to chime in also and
really for me the question is
how does the legislature chime in we
don't want to impede
whatever the governor is doing because
just as we are all elected officials the
governor is an elected official also
and the governor is going to have to
answer to the people for the things
that he or she does or does not do
but should we be standing in the way
and i think with like a lot of new
hampshire citizens
there's a lot of frustration over how
long colvin went
that maybe it went it went on too long
and i would agree that you know in
august of last year we're like yeah hey
you know why are we still doing this and
that's because the governor
had information that we were going to
get that second wind and we started to
hear about that
second wind that was coming and it came
it came and that's why the emergency
orders were continued
um in fact i think that the the second
wave of coven
was worse than the first we experienced
more deaths more sicknesses than we did
during the first time so
yes i know representative rory talked
about you know
not so much about hindsight and coving
but moving forward
but i do think it's important that we
look back at the experience
um and what what was the role that the
legislature
could have played and i agree that at
some point the legislator
legislature should have been involved
especially with
the emergency orders and the policy
issues
and maybe people would have felt a
little more comfortable
with knowing that the legislature was
actively involved
in these policy issues representative
representatives senator gaida
and i sat on the governor's task force
and that was pretty intensive in the
very beginning
where we were working hand-in-hand with
businesses and industries
about what we could open how we were
going to open them and open them safely
for the people and you know again
it was a lot of work we were meeting
five days a week for
for real yeah for at least three months
and then we continued to meet
um on a regular schedule to discuss
issues and
as things got better those those
emergency orders those those other
things were loosened
up um and i think that it was the right
thing to do because it was a
very very delicate balance and i
understand there were a lot of people
who were very angry
and we know a lot of people lost their
businesses and so on and so forth
and that's not trivializing anything
but it was what we found ourselves into
and a lot of it was dictated by the
federal government in the cdc
i hope we never ever have to go through
anything like that again
and i've actively encouraged the
governor to put together a task force
where we can take a look at what we did
right what we did wrong and what we need
to improve on
and i see this as part of that is what
really is the legislature's role
when we have states of emergency and we
need to issue
executive orders but how deeply do you
want to
micromanage this how how hard do you
want to tie the governor's hands that's
what i'm struggling with
okay so i understand the micromanagement
that's why i think the change to
the house bill to remove the requirement
that we have to approve
individual emergency orders because
you know that lets the governor respond
in the timely manner
having to approve the extension of the
emergency state of emergency
especially after 45 days is
that's not i don't see that as
management because that's
we see that coming ahead the governor
will have time to get information to us
um you know who can consider that
and so that's more of a let's see kind
of a
longer term policy thing it's not
dealing with not limiting immediate
responses
the other thing is is you know let's say
in august the legislature decided to
have a state of emergency
you know even in face of the governor's
recommendation
to that it did look like there was a
surge actually coming i don't see the
same reason
at that point sometime later and then as
far as the
issue of getting the federal money i've
seen arguments on both sides saying we
could have got it without a state state
of emergency because the federal one
but regardless of that you know the
governor could if that's the case the
governor could let the legislature know
and say okay we need the state of
emergency for this reason
um but you know i'm going to limit you
know
remove most of the emergency orders that
maybe aren't necessary
continuous state of emergency but with
dramatically less restrictions
largely or maybe not terrible largely so
we can get that money
there's nothing to prevent that from
discussion
you know the legislature would have
developed so i think i think it leads to
a lot of flexibility and gives us some
flexibility
to the extent and limit what it does
i don't see anything in here that would
limit the legislature
from calling a special session to
discuss any sort of policies
policy emergency orders that any
governor would institute
and i think that's a strong tool that
the legislature does have
to keep a check on the governor and
whatever policy changes the governor
makes either
to say yes we just we agree or no we
disagree
so um i don't think we need to put that
in there
in the bill but for discussion purposes
we're already able to do something
i mean last year while we were in
lockdown
and it was march and it was april and i
know i was sitting there going okay what
are we going to do now
um the legislature could have been
called
called in at any point in time and we
could have met we could have met and we
could have discussed
the policy changes the appropriate
committee chairs could have gotten
together
but the governor still would have signed
right
but then again that's holding the
governor accountable
because if the governor said i don't
like this and i'm not going to sign it
the people are going to hold you
responsible for that aren't they
they are but in the two years until the
next election we've lost businesses
we've
lost all kinds of things which is why he
gets 45 days on this proposal
unrestricted to do what he needs to do
if it's longer than 45 days he still
gets to
we just have to extend the emergency
we're not micromanaging we're not saying
you can't do this you can't do that if
he doesn't order we don't like
we can receive the order but before
anything beyond 45 days is a long period
of time
and it doesn't take that long for a
business to fold and if you're saying
he's accountable
to the elector absolutely he is in two
years
so i mean we were into a year and a half
of an emergency order when we started
talking about this
we heard that there were almost no
emergencies
states of virginia there was i think the
all-state flood was extended once
to wrap up the repairs but most of them
were 21 days an hour so
if that 45 days that will take care of
almost anything the definition of
emergence means
disruption once that has happened now
you start instituting policies and
procedures for one reversal
a public health emergency is no less of
an emergency and this is
that these are extraordinary
circumstances
and hopefully we will never be here
again
but in order you know so i think there
had to be
there had to be actions taken and they
were certainly detrimental to some of
the
businesses and constituents in my
district as well
but the conversation was about the
greater good you couldn't see this
emergency
like a tornado or a flood but this is
exactly what we've been preparing for
in the state of new hampshire since
after hurricane katrina
and 9 11. so it's it's no less of an
emergency
it's just so extraordinary so what
lessons
have we learned that we can maybe not i
you know what lessons have we learned
and how should we respond in the future
keeping
keeping that in mind i'm you know
i i wonder if we're missing the
opportunity to really look at that
by you know can we do something very
very
minimal and at the same time
have a commission or a study group that
really looks at the impacts
all around to make union c's do we need
to have something larger
put in place but that's what this bill
is intended to be
is the fairly minimal changes we have
another bill
that will be changing dna
because yeah this is this is an outline
and it addresses what we saw were the
biggest issues
namely that it could be continued
forever
and ever and ever we thought was a
concern
there's also the point that some of the
emergency orders
engaged on policy and should have been
approved and so we wanted to be able to
even if
the state of emergency continued we
wanted to be able to say
to the governor cancel this emergency
order
you're doing the policy decision and not
telling you what to do to say don't do
it this way
one of the biggest issues that we
discussed that
i got from my constituency what made you
draft this is communication
even on the committee that you were on
you were trimming certain things in the
governor
prior to certain things but as a
legislative told
we found out about american orders
saying everyone else
so when my phone rings and says why does
the government do this
i don't know i i wasn't part of that
discussion
[Music]
so there was a distinct lack of
communication now
because i want to support god he's my
governor i want us towards policies but
i can't afford hawaii
the communication is very important i
think
[Music]
so here we go
i think there is a provision in the
constitution
where the governor calls a special
session if we are out of session
so that's something that you need to
think about as well
what happens if at the end of this 45
days
were were passed to june 30th and the
governor has to call the special session
what are you going to do then we have
the ability to call
ourselves
yeah um so i think we have just a few
a few changes we have a few changes to
make
and we will um
so senator do you want to get those
changes
or should
should we would late this afternoon work
for all of you or do we have up to we
have conflicts
i am in committee's conference till four
until after four this afternoon
[Music]
all right so i've got a four
and it would have to be after do we have
a 24-hour
department requirements
okay so anytime tomorrow would work and
we can get a room
but he would be in this room sometimes
we're following
our hopes for photoshop and first
meeting tomorrow
so we could meet in the morning
i can't find me before
[Music]
if the first meeting is at 1 30 i could
be more of a long it's fine
um
will we have enough time well we've got
the line yeah it's just
looking at the language okay so we agree
uh um
most of the principles at least okay one
o'clock tomorrow
[Music]
thank you thank you